so you know the i-team first reported
the name of the driver suspected of
hitting trooper may
yesterday's but this morning the clark
county coroner confirmed the information
officially released his name which was
douglas claiborne the itunes vanessa
murphy talked with his attorney and
friend and she's here with the interview
that you're seeing here first
on 8 news now vanessa denise douglas
claiborne's attorney tells me he and
claiborne's family are exploring ways to
try to help
trooper may and his family possibly
through a fund
he also says he understands police had
to address
the threat claiborne posed
it's really sad it's just really really
tragic 60 year old douglas claiborne
stole this car
led police on a chase and hit trooper
micah may as he was putting stop sticks
on the road according to nevada highway
patrol
trooper may critically injured and
airlifted to the hospital
claiborne shot and killed being so
violent
and then again involving an innocent
police officer it's horrible
attorney victor bakke says he's
represented claiborne for the past 15
years
he also calls him a friend in an
interview from hawaii with the i-team he
says
he's expected a call about claiborne i
expected it to just be
that there was an overdose or
some type of accident or something like
that bucky and claiborne's father tell
the i-team he struggled with drugs for
years
and both believe he was high on tuesday
he just
had a horrible horrible drug addiction
to methamphetamine
and he had all the opportunities in the
world to
be happy healthy and successful he says
claiborne was the beneficiary of a
substantial trust fund but his addiction
led to a lengthy criminal history
spanning multiple states including
nevada iowa texas and hawaii
here's a mug shot from 2007 in dallas
compared to this one from 2020 in las
vegas
that's when he was arrested for battery
but the case was dropped
bucky also confirms previous arrests for
robbery assault making a terror threat
abusing family and felony drug charges
according to records he was part of a
plan to smuggle drugs into jail and then
spent time in federal prison
in hindsight i wish i could have left
him in there because
he was safe he was happy records reveal
his time in the federal
system ended in 2019. bacchi says
claiborne dramatically deteriorated
since then
his final moments spent on this crime
rampage
police had to neutralize that threat
i asked bakke if family and friends
tried to get claiborne into a program to
try to stay clean
he says he would get sober and then
relapse but again he was doing well with
the structure and program
in federal prison both bakke and
claiborne's father tell me
they had not heard from claiborne
recently he lived mainly in hawaii but
frequently traveled to las vegas
his father also expressed sorrow for
what has happened to trooper may